nous l'explique depuis zapporage à notre
envoyé spécial Gwendoline de Bono
Kiev annonce des progrès
particulièrement justement sur ce front
de l'Est le ministère de la Défense dit
qu'il y a tous les jours des avances
notamment sur les flancs de la ville de
barmouth c'est une chose le ministère de
la Défense qui dit que tous les jours
les soldats irréalistes des programmes
et pour l'instant ils ne sont pas entrés
dans la ville ça c'est une chose un peu
plus au sud dans la région de deniers ce
que et bien les soldats ukrainiens ont
repris un village qui lui se situe sur
l'axe de progression de la grande ville
portuaire de Mario Paul et puis on voit
également qu'il se passe des choses dans
la région de Kerson ou des petites
unités
ukrainiennes ont été capables de
franchir le Nièvre pour aller opérer en
zone occupée ceci étant dit il s'agit de
petits progrès l'Ukraine on est toujours
à la première phase de sa
contre-offensive qui consiste à aller
tester les défenses russes à essayer et
bien de comprendre où se situent les
faiblesses pour plus tard lancer un
assaut de plus grand d'ampleur avec par
exemple des brigades mécanisées mais
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas il
s'agit toujours de la première phase de
cette contre-offensive et d'ailleurs sur
les 12 brigades qui ont été formés pour
cette contre-offensive par les
partenaires occidentaux et bien neufs
n'ont toujours pas été déployés sur le
terrain et ça c'est un indicateur qu'on
est toujours dans la première phase de
cette contre-offensive
et le ministre de la Défense ukrainien
explique aujourd'hui au Financial Times
que la libération des quelques villages
d'ukrainien occupés par les Russes n'est
qu'un avant-goût de l'offensive prévue
par Kiev